So, good morning, everyone.
Welcome to the DDPS seminar.
Before we introduce our invited
speaker today, let's go over
some rules as usual. First of
all, please mute yourself during
the talk. If you have immediate
questions, you're welcome to
unmute and ask or otherwise,
please use the chat room to pose
your question and show that we
will address your questions at
the end
in the q&a session. Second,
today's seminar is open to extra
external audience so no
classified discussion is
allowed. Finally, the talk will
be recorded and upload to our
YouTube channel. Now, let me
introduce our speaker. It is an
honor to host Matias Cho who
goes by tear tear is currently
an associate professor in the
Department of Mathematics at
Emory University since 2022.
Before that, he held faculty
positions at Virginia Tech and
Texas State University, and he
was a postdoctoral fellow at
Emory University. He obtained
his doctorate degree from the
University of Lubbock and
master's degree from the
University of Hamburg, both in
Germany. Thea is a Humboldt
fellow and an active member of
Siam. The focus of TMS research
is on solving ill posed and
large scale inverse problems
with applications in different
disciplines, such as image
processing, dynamical systems,
he develops and analyzed,
efficient numerical methods with
regularization, randomized
methods, patient immersion, and
scientific machine learning to
date here will present his work
on big data in real problems,
promoting sparsity and learning
to recognize, please enjoy the
wonderful talk. Now without
further ado, let me hand it to
Tia by asking one random
question. So besides Atlanta,
and Savannah, what is your
favorite city in Georgia?
In Georgia? Savannah.
So when I did you exclude
Savannah? Yeah, maybe excluding
Savannah? Okay. So maybe Athens,
I need to go then to Georgia
State.
University of Georgia, which is
nice town over there. Yeah, I
heard that also. Okay. Yeah.
Yeah, the stage is all yours
right now. Okay. Thanks so much
for having me, Tony. And for
introduce for the introduction,
I'm very excited to talk about
some of my research with you.
And and
that can be also a discussion
about about some new directions.
And I'm very happy if you
interrupt me if you have any
questions or comment comments
throughout the talk. So I would
be happy about that. So
let me start here. Let's see.
Oh, yeah, there we go. I wanted
to start with a little bit more
of my introduction. So first of
all, here in the front, you see
Emory University. And in the
background, you see the skyline
from Atlanta. So that is a
pretty city, as well. And I'm
sitting right in this building
here with a observatory over
here somewhere at the side. And
of course, it's not for right
now, but very green, light green
at the moment. So Emory
University is nicely located
close to Atlanta, or in Atlanta.
And, yeah, it's always nice to
visit that place. All right.
As Tony already said, so my work
is somewhere in the field of
inverse problems, machine,
scientific machine learning UQ,
dynamical systems all involved.
And I just made it a little bit
schematic over here. So in in
the intersection of these
methods, nevertheless, central
to all what I'm doing two major
things, and that is a model and
data. And with that, I think I
fit somehow within the theme of
the seminar, which is data
driven, physical simulations. So
what I'm particularly interested
in is inverse problems. So here
I'm did a very simple sketch of
what are they derive more of
what I assumed what is data
model driven? If I have just
data given my model model, less
information could be just a line
and I cannot extrapolate
information out of this regime
where my data gives me good
information.
On the other hand, if I would
have just a model, the model
lines could go lie everywhere.
When I don't have any proper
information. However, both
together might give me good
predictions for future events or
for
Why
things we haven't observed.
So this is a big regime. And
today, I want to talk
specifically about inverse
problem and how, how better to
illustrate this with some
images. And I give here, just a
simple image, the glaring
example, this one here, let's
assume that it's all true image.
And let's assume we have some
blur in there. And we assume
this is done by some forward
operation, maybe some kernel,
some Gaussian kernel, and we get
a blurred image. And actually,
interest is coming from a
blurred and noisy image to go
back to the true image. So we
can write this down as a linear
problem. And we have done that
many, many times, before going
the opposite direction, is
essentially just inverting the
operator, and we should get back
our image. If we were to do that
here in this example, that leads
to a total failure of recovering
the information we actually
want, although I have the true
model in there. So what happens
so the part of inverse problems
is that it is ill posed meaning
noise in the data, or in the
model or in the Numerix, even
though can be amplified. So and
that is summarized by the notion
of powerlessness, or ill
conditioned of an operator and
we say a problem is ill posed if
a solution does not exist, is
not unique, or does not depend
continuously on the data. And
that goes back to what Mr. We
are seeing here on the very
right.
All right, that that is more or
less the stage of inverse
problems and illustrated with
some, some images. And we can
write this in many different
forms. And I don't want to take
the Bayesian approach, I will
here just look at the
variational approach, we
typically have a data
fidelity term or loss function
between the model and the data.
And to stabilize the data fit,
we need some prior knowledge,
which is encoded in typically
some regularization. And this
regularization might depend in
some of some hyper parameters,
which are imposed regularization
parameters, or in your, in your
Gaussian, or if you have other
distributions, where your
regularizer comes from some
other terms, which might
influence
your prior knowledge, which you
want to introduce into your
system. So as we have seen
earlier, just looking at the
data, fidelity, John might lead
to an ill posed problem, and we
need to establish
this standard example here is
taken off problem where we have
a data fidelity form over here
with some regularization term,
where we want the solution to be
close, yes, somehow, in some
sense to zero. That is the
standard setup. And of course,
we are doing this for many,
many, many years. But how Where
are still the challenges? And
one thing is definitely the
dimensionality is if we think
about, yeah, training a neural
network as an inverse problem is
definitely the dimensionality
involved in that or if we have
reconstructions of some medical
MRI images, which are four four
dimensional, then this problem
goes fast out of hand and
standard methods do not
necessarily apply. Another
thing, which I already
talked a little bit about is the
regularization. It's how do I
include this for example, how do
I take a regularization
parameter, this is up royally
not necessarily known. It is
sometimes derived from the noise
distribution of our problem, but
that is not necessarily there.
And the last thing is probably
the uncertainty quantification.
If we want for large scale
problems, also to know a little
bit about how certain we are
about our inverse solution, then
this one is typically
computationally very expensive,
and this is a challenge to work
on that.
All right, I will mostly talk
about the first two parts and
for now at least ignore a little
bit uncertainty finding
vacation but although it is a
topic on its own.
Alright, more specifically, I
want to talk about
a new project and new method we
developed and this is what we
call variable projected
augmented Lagrangian. And now
we'll get into a lot of details
over there, the Arctic paper you
can find over here.
We're lucky to get some funding
and I want to acknowledge NSF
there and this is a joint
project with Rosie we're not and
Petrus three nails.
All right, let's dive into that
and look at the following. I
want to solve the following
inverse problems here I have a
data fidelity term and you see
I, for simplicity, I'm looking
at a linear problem and some
regularization term. And you saw
taken off regularization has a 2
million square here we look at a
one norm and some matrix d over
here as well with some operator
which
we want to project our solution
onto. And typically what we want
is sparsity in our solution and
L one
zero type norm is not suitable
or computationally too
expensive, we use the one norm
over here, which promotes
sparsity in general is rip
condition is satisfied and so
on. Nevertheless, we have done
that many times. And this is
typically referred to as a
generalized lasso problem, the
generalized come through an
operator da, otherwise, we just
call it lasso problem.
All right, and some
regularization parameter over
here.
All right, so to give you an
example, where these type of
problems come up, and this is
definitely a similar
signal processing, more
specifically signal compression,
where the signal needs to
compress and you want a lot of
pieces to be zero compressed
sensing. And you already see
these are all topics which came
up especially in the late 2000s
and started 2000s. And
dictionary learning is something
else but also denoising image
deep learning and other things,
I will talk about a couple of
potential applications, it's a
wide variety, which we can look
at.
So, this generalized lasso is
computationally expensive, since
we need iterative methods to
solve this, we cannot directly
solve it like the chicken off
problems, if we have not enough
not too large problem, and we
can just invert but here we
typically need iterative method.
And it is computed internally
more challenging than for
example, that
then the point I already made
also here, we typically don't
know the regularization
parameter, how can we determine
this parameter, especially in
the sentence, or in the settings
of L one regularization, which
is not standard, many tools have
been developed for the L two
norm for the chicken off problem
with the L. One, it is a little
bit harder.
Of course, there is a zoo of
methods out there to attack this
generalized lasso problem. And I
stated a couple of
methods over here. And if you
want to, I actually put one more
animal into into the zoo, but I
want to convince you that there
is a good reason and to use
these kind of methods. Alright,
to start with, I just want to be
on the same page that everyone
can hopefully follow. I want to
introduce ADMM and derive it and
just see how we develop the
variable protected augmented
Lagrangian.
Alright,
let's keep going. So this was
our problem over here. And we
can reformulate ages by
introducing just a surrogate
variable, here, the y. And what
we do is we are just enforcing
the Y to be equal to dx. We're
just replacing this piece. In
general, that might be a bad
idea. Everyone who has some
optimization will say okay, a
constrained optimization problem
is significantly harder than an
unconstrained optimization
problem. Why would we do that?
Well,
We'll get to that. So the first
thing you do is okay, I have
this constraint problem, I form
a lot the logwatch function and
include also a penalty term. And
this is a quadratic penalty term
where we call this the augmented
Lagrangian here, I have my
Lagrangian multipliers over
here. And this is my augmented
Lagrangian where I not enforce
it strictly, but have some
penalty term when y is not equal
to dx.
And
you see that the last two terms
are some quadratic terms. And we
can reshuffle these bowls and
just reformulate this both
together to have it in this
form, which is easier to, to
handle. And then the c takes the
form of our Lagrange multiplier
with some some factor over here.
Of course, the lambda over here
is an additional penalty
parameter, which penalizes our
nonconformity to our constraint.
All right, this is augmented
Lagrangian. And before I start
talking about ADMM, again, I
want to scale back and say,
let's look at a generic
function. And for simplicity,
let let f be strictly convex.
And I want to assume it's
separable. Meaning I have two
sets of variables, which have
different meanings or which I
can separate, you can think
about, if you are familiar with
a lot of training neural
networks, each layer has a set
of
parameters and they have
different meanings, they are
interact,
but they have different meanings
or might live on different
scales, right, or you may have
some linear parameters and some
nonlinear parameters.
How can you solve these kinds of
generic problems. So actually,
what we have seen this, we just
artificially introduced variable
in our previous slide. So this
one can come through an Yeah,
reformulation of a separate into
a separate problem, or naturally
appearing in applications and
one example is super resolution,
where you have a lot of small
images, and you want to
reconstruct largest image with
sub pixel information.
Let me tell you what we could
do. So the first approach is
just ignore that we have two
different variables, right, and
just combine them both together
and take your favorite method to
use an iterative optimization
method, maybe that's a some
gradient descent method, or
some, some BFGS, or whatever
optimization method you want.
Over here, and you want to
minimize that, go back. Sorry
for that. And this is one
approach, that oftentimes
suffers some slow convergence,
especially if the Para variables
are on different scales or have
very different meanings. To
combat this, there are typically
two approaches which you can use
one is called in the descent,
what you're doing there is
you're taking your favorite
optimization method, again,
going in one direction, a step,
and then in the other direction
step, and you're continuing this
process over and over again.
And there's a third approach,
which is called alternating
direction, and the alternating
direction, instead of going a
step in a direction you're
optimizing in this direction,
and then you optimize in the
opposite direction. And you
continue this approach over and
over again.
So and I think this is lost. In
illustration, over here, we are
very close to our ADMM method,
alternating direction, we had
two variables in here, and we
are alternating essentially over
this verb. So that is ADMM.
Essentially, essentially, you
have an update on your parameter
X, minimizing this problem over
here, then you update your y
minimizing this problem and the
Lagrange multiplier and I don't
want to say too much that you
can update them as well. Instead
of increasing the penalty
parameter, you can use this
approach. So now, let's digest
this a little bit. And what what
just happened. So first of all,
we have here suddenly linearly
squares problems since our y is
constant. This one is now easy
to solve, right? We know we can
solve a linear least squares
problems, since y is constant.
That's perfect, wonderful to do.
The second thing is this guy
over here, if you look at the
why it goes in here and here and
is not convoluted by a matrix
means all these optimization
problems are independent, first
of all, and it is the so called
shrinkage problem. So we can
actually have an analytic
solution for that, by this
computer.
It's not complicated, but but it
might have an easy update for
me. Okay, details, we don't need
to know about this, right. But
this is fairly straightforward
and to do.
And then the last part is the
update on the Lagrange
multipliers.
So if we look at this method,
where is the computational most
effort we need to put in that
is, of course, the first part
over here, then I have some
matrices A and D, and I need to
solve this linear
problem. So if I take a standard
method, it will be somehow of
the complexity of some however,
many iterations I took in my
auto iteration, times the
dimensionality times and square
some somewhere around this. But
of course, since line four is
the most expensive one, we
typically do an iterative method
to solve this. And we don't even
potentially accurately solve
that maybe go just a couple of
iterations, right?
Another way is to do pre the the
pre computed decomposition of
these matrices before and
because you're always applying
the same matrix. So you can
could do something like that as
the factorization if you
consider consider the normal
equations, right? Something like
that.
All right. So, so far, so good,
and that is ADMM. But I didn't
tell you that there is actually
a fourth option of what we
discussed earlier. And the
fourth option is the variable
projection.
Before we did optimization
optimization as updates that
updates that or ignoring, but
you can also hibernate this
update in one direction, and
optimize in the other one.
And this is what we call a
variable projection. And we can
actually write it in this form,
like I showed over here and
update just of X and somehow
eliminate the second variable
within the first burger.
Okay, so this one was actually
developed in the early 70s by
cola era. And that was
particularly that for the
separable nonlinear problems,
where you have a of x where x is
a nonlinear operator or
nonlinear parameter, determining
your operator, and y is a linear
variable. So for this, it has
been developed. And we could
easily apply this also for, for
the generalized lasso approach.
So all we need to do is changing
line for when we do an update on
the linear problem, and then
solve for the second one. I want
to just to emphasize over here
that we do an X actually
opposite to what what, what the
variable projection was intended
to. And that is
updating the linear and
optimizing over the nonlinear
because the non year is actually
straightforward. So this is what
we call them variable projected
augmented Grandstream.
And if you look at this,
did I have it over here? I think
my might have put it in the next
slide. This is a projected
problem over here. And several
nice things happen to to this
update is if I compute gradient
information, the nonlinear
problem goes away because we
have optimality. So a lot of
computational pieces will get
easier.
Here, you could, for example,
steak as the step direction, the
negative gradient, right
That would be one option. But
there are other choices, right.
And this is just one one of.
And I also could compute a line
search parameter actually, I
could, for simplicity here, just
use the linearize line search
parameter, the optimal
linearize, nine search
parameter, and then it would be
something like a conjugate
gradients, just one conjugate
gradient step in my linear
problem.
And the content computational
cost, if I'm looking at this
algorithm, it just reduces here
from n squared to n. That is,
what the differences. And since
we are now in the realm of
standard optimization methods, I
could use any optimization
method to use for my for my
search direction, and standard
stopping criteria as you can
impose on on this unconstrained
optimization.
All right, so I think it is a
good time to first look, look at
an example of how this works.
Let's, let's let's let's see
that, or I just summarized
everything, again, over here was
a particular choice. This is
just a simple choice I can think
of to make it
work, then my thing is about
they're just matrix vector
multiplies. There's no inversion
in there. And the algorithm is
very straightforward. So there's
no SQL, which I need to pack in
there, like with ADMM, and so
on, this will just need per
iteration to matrix vector
multiplies with A and D and one
transpose or one, I joined for
that for each.
All right.
Before I show the Numerix, just
just a quick and I put a couple
of things under the rock, but we
can show that if we use the
variable protected romantic
Lagrangian method, and we can
show that the method will
converge, there's uniqueness, we
need to show uniqueness of the
projected problem. And then we
need to show that the variable
projection method converges, and
then later on that augmented
Lagrangian method converges, and
we are coupling all of these
elements together, then into
one.
All right, so now now we have
time for some numerical
experiments. Let's start with a
couple of things. First of all,
this is a de noising problem,
the simples what we can think of
so the operator A is just the
identity. And the D operator
here comes from total variation,
meaning what I actually want in
the derivative derivative in
each direction, I want just a
few jumps, right. And that is
what the D operator does over
here. So it's a two D, two,
total variation,
we are comparing to ADM, and
there we use LS QR for the inner
solve. And here for just
illustration, we pick a
regularization parameter 10 and
a standard stopping criteria
takes 10 to the minus four. And
let's see how both of these
methods perform. So, here on the
left, you see the iteration
count and the red residual over
here and a lock 10 And here is
the arrow over here. So, what
you will see is that the
residual and also the arrows go
nearly to the identical value.
So relative errors are nearly
identical.
But what you see see is ADMM
uses less iterations, then we
use
however, this is an arbitrary
count, right? Because what does
iterations really mean? So, we
want to look at what is the
actual work we are doing. So, we
are looking at the wall clock
time.
And there the picture looks very
different. If we look on the
left, we are looking at sizes of
this image and just increase the
sizes. And we also compare to
taken off solution of course,
taken off as just a linear
invert inversion and the time is
very fast. However, the
reconstruction will be terrible.
Because that is not we want
don't want an L to
regularize over here. And if you
look at the wall clock time,
that blue one the V V Powell
variable projection and method
is significantly faster, despite
they both produce essentially
the same image, the curves of
the relative error lie on the
same path over here
And if we look at the timings
over here, how ADMM Fizzers
report looks like it is, yeah,
between seven and nine speed up.
And I also looked at the number
of
matrix vector multiplications,
which I needed within ADMM. Or
deeper
that I was already encouraging.
Let me show you another image
over here that came from the
beginning.
The girl was at all earring over
here. And what I just did, I
did an inpainting example. And
there's essentially an indicator
function, which we have over
here. And what I did as a small
test is what happens when I
change my regularization
parameter, too much timing and
to my relative error. And you
see, if I take a small
regularization error, then my
timing is very bad. And if I
take it too high, it will be bad
as well. But when I hit around
about a good reconstruction,
that method is fairly fast.
So that shows the importance of
regularization property. But how
do I select this work?
And there are many different
methods already out there. As I
mentioned, discrepancy
principle, up rd, and
generalized cross validation,
they're all methods, which we
can utilize. However, they get a
little bit computationally
expensive. And they don't
generalize to the L one, so
easily more needs to be put in
there. What we took a different
approach, we said, we want to
learn the regularization. So
what we assume is there is a
mapping from our observation to
our regularization parameter.
And I put this boldface here,
since we think about this not
only as a regularization
parameter, some hyper parameters
or some information about your
priors,
you can construct an neural
network, which you parameterize
to approximate this mapping, and
you learn this mapping. And
here, I just for completeness, I
just wrote down a new on the
network, but I think I don't
need to, in this crowd, go
through many details there, you
know, what a neural network is,
you're mapping from B to the
regular zation. And it's
parameterised with all the
weights and bias terms, and you
will want to learn on the
parameters in this network to
get a good mapping from B to the
regularization. That means, once
I've learned this,
a new B, I'm getting, I just
need to forward propagate
through my network and get a
regularization.
Just some details on the how we
pick the loss function and so
on. And let me just summarize
what we do the learning is an
offline phase, we generate some
training data, some B and some
Optima regularization parameter,
we can do that since we are in
the training phase, and we know
the underlying truth over there.
Then we set up the neural
network and learn the neural
network from this data in the
offline phase, we get a new B
propagate forward, and then we
can compute the inverse problem.
So notice here, I don't want to
throw away the physical model.
Right? I'm learning just on the
prior, I don't learn the mapping
from B to the reconstructions. I
want to still have the physics
in my system, but I want to
induce inflammation on my
prayer.
All right, here is a simple
example for heat equation one
the heat equation, just proof of
concept. And he I looked a look
at the taken off problem
generated a bunch of random
signals with some noise and I
even chose different noise
levels right with this, I can do
this all however I want.
I compare this methods to UPI,
ie GCV. These are standard
methods and discrepancy
principle I cut out because
otherwise you wouldn't see
anything in the picketers that
perform underperformed
significantly. There's another
method which is on on the
optimal experiment comes from
optimal experimental design. And
then I use two different neural
networks. One is a dnn and one
is an RM or extreme learning
machine, which is just a linear
network essentially
Without
activation.
So as we learn on some training
data, so let me show you the
results over here. On the left
hand side, you will look at the
test set. And we look at the
difference between our recovered
parameter and the optimal. And I
use all these different methods,
this is should be an I O ID
sorry for that. And, of course,
it should be around zero, that
would be optimal, right. So, to
hit the optimal parameters, and
you'll see, the DNS performs
extremely well over here
compared to any of the
statistical methods, or to the
linearized model.
If we translate this in the
reconstruction arrow over here,
in the right hand side, you will
see, this is the optimal I can
do and the black over here and I
can zoom in and you see, the dnn
pretty much captured very well.
Right.
Okay, that is good.
All right. So, the disadvantage
of of standard method is,
is that it is very expensive to
compute the regularization
parameter, and it is not always
optimal. But you don't need any
learning process within that why
dnn seven yd s needs learning to
generate you regularization
parameter.
But the dnn is performed
extremely well and adapted to
your data. Once you get a new
data in, you get a new
regularization prompt. And
especially for these data, which
I was presented.
I took one more example from
tomography over here, which is
also a linear operation. And I
slowly curve back to the
generalized lasso problem.
Let me go back. If you don't are
not familiar with tomography
tomography,
you essentially have a source
and a receiver over here and
you're having line integrals and
you
compute that attenuation
coefficient, and you are
essentially put your data in one
line you are observed over here,
and then you're rotating and
input all the data on here. But
from this, we call it sinogram.
You want to reconstruct the
image. And this is the shape
Logan Phantom. And they are
randomized ship logon we use for
training, this data over here.
The set up is as we had before,
with some noise levels. And I
don't want to go into the
details only that we use a
regularization now, which is the
generalized lasso problem, where
we cannot so easily use
statistical standard statistical
methods to estimate the
regularization. And here are
some test images or training
images we have over here. And
let me just do quickly, the dnn
set up of course, this we are
operating on images. So we are
talking about Convolutional
Neural Networks makes the
training easier.
Small mode not on that actually
training this network to the
regularization form it is
extremely easy. You're going to
one dimension, this is not large
dimensional problem, right,
you're going from a large
dimensional to a one dimensional
part which is
piece of cake for these neural
networks.
Okay, that is all set up. How we
learn we do use atom and mini
batches with certain learning
rate over here.
And I look at the two different
dnns, the dnn and
the shallow network over over
here and you see the optimal
regularization parameter
compared to the to the optimal
compared to the learned
regularization parameter. And if
this one is
around this line over here would
be best and you'll see that dnn
does pretty well, the LRM cannot
learn so well. Because it's a
linear mapping, you might get
even negative regularization
parameters, which in this case
is not of any value. Okay, so
how how does now the performance
look there? If I look at the
distribution of my discrepancy
between my learned one and the
optimal one, I see I'm very well
performed very
Well With My dnn
looking over here with a
relative error, and the density
over here, the optimal is
highlighted in black, and the
dnn, I think we can ignore the
linear the neural network, it
performs pretty well. And I want
to point something out, which I
was surprised about. And that
is,
why is our new neural network
better than the optimal one that
cannot be? And
I, at a certain point, notice
that the optimal regularization
parameter, I numerically solved.
And in some cases, it didn't
find it wasn't a local minima.
And it never found the optimal
one, why the neural net network
was able to compensate even for
that, which was very impressive.
Of course, we did a lot of other
experiments, for example, took
out total out of sample images,
which generated still very sick,
very good results. All right,
I'm circling back to a couple of
applications to give you some
time. Give us some time for for
discussion. This is a very
exciting recent work, we are
working on five d MRI, cardiac
MRI, and if you asked me what
five d MRI is, I don't know what
the five d actually means. Yeah.
That
it sounds strange, but it comes
not from me, okay. The point
five d means actually, it comes
through two different phases,
respiratory and the cardiac and
you want to reconstruct
3d volume in time was a
respiratory and cardiac phase.
And this was a project we, we
just recently started, and we
looked at ADMM, which they
standard used, and we just
implemented V. Powell, on a very
small scale. And this is a
timing from 14.4 hours to 4.5.
And that is just just the
simplest form we could do. That
is just the starting point. And
if you think about you want your
results of a cardiac image, very
fast, 14.4 hours is not
reasonable. But 4.5 goes already
in this right direction.
Nevertheless, in the beginning,
I showed you a speed up of seven
to nine, where they're not there
yet. So there's still something
to do. There's also other two
methods we can use or under
sampling, where we are now, not
yet. Nevertheless, the sizes of
the problem are extremely large,
and data size is extremely
large. And
these methods are
performing pretty well on this
example.
A question I often get is,
what is where's the difference
between variable projection
augmented Lagrangian compared to
ADMM.
And then ADM m where you don't
solve all till the very end,
actually, we never do this
right, you have an inexact ADMM
and that's what most people are
using. However, in ADMM, the Y
is always fixed in the first
problem to optimize over x or to
find an x here, we don't need
this here, it is adopted because
we are on a different manifold.
And this I just illustrate by
using for example, a linear
different regularization,
different step size different
learning rate over here, which
is not just the linearized one,
if I choose that, I go to the
con convergence much faster over
here in just 40 iteration or 30
iteration compare to 120. Why
the step lengths so is
significantly different. So the
methods are really different
there you are operating on
different manifests.
Because there are so many
applications I want to just show
you some I played around with
which are just fun to do. And
this one is for example,
trend graph trend filtering
where with missing data, so you
have here, for example, the
roadmap nap of Minnesota, and
you have some trend in the data,
and there are some missing black
dots and you want to read,
reconstruct this information of
the two data and you can
Do that RIA L one
regularization, here, the
operator looks a little bit
different than just the
standard, find a difference.
One, but it is fun, fun to play
these kinds of problems. And
they they are solved very fast.
Here's another problem, which I
mentioned already in the
beginning. So which is super
resolution, you have a bunch of
small resolution images. And now
I put 10. A Tony on the spot.
What do you think what the is?
Can you identify what the image
is?
An astronaut. Yeah, exactly.
That's an astronaut. And if you
actually do the sub pixel
information, and you do the
reconstruction, this is a true
one in this reconstruction I'm
getting it was the power over
here. I don't know if I have
another example. I have one
more. But that is already in my
conclusion, I think I finished
up hopefully, about in time. So
my first three years federal
protection is under utilized.
And it is fun to play with that
and can give surprisingly good
results and many different ways.
We used it also and, and
training neural networks,
separable neural networks, which
I didn't talk about today. But
if you're looking at some spots
recover with some lateral
problems, people have some fast
convergence. Of course, this is
just the beginning of things we
are investigating. One thing is
I so far, I talked about
nonlinear linear operators,
Nanya operators, we don't need
to change our code. Our code
works for nonlinear operators as
well. But we haven't played with
that as well. So if there are
some nonlinear PDE is involved
with that, that will be very
interesting. We just last week,
try to do
dictionary learning here you see
the first results, actually, I
have already better results. So
we ran it already twice and the
dictionary learning but more to
come in the future. I didn't
talk about much about changing
the norms, you can do this with
a separable function as well. If
you are separating the splitting
of the variables, you can
leverage, there are some points
as well.
My collaborator works on joint
inversion at the moment, if you
have two different modalities,
and you want to join this
information. For example, in sub
surface imaging, we are doing
that right now. And looking at
some results over there. I
talked very briefly about
convergence. But there's still a
lot more to do. And where I want
to go and I spent some time on
randomized methods, I want to
include them in this framework
as well so that we can go to
larger dimensions even then we
are doing right now, I talked a
bit about the selection of the
regularization parameter. But
there is still lots to do and
depends a little bit still on
the operator, how can we get
information out of that, that's
also something we are currently
working on. And I just showed
you this simple version of the
puzzle with a certain
descent direction, and step size
selection. But we can generalize
this. And we can use different
things. We already started that
as well. And it works fine. But
there's still a long way to go.
And with this. I'm happy to take
any questions. Thank you,
everyone.
Yeah, thank you very much, RTF
for the wonderful talk. I
believe everyone enjoyed his
talk as much as I do. So now is
the q&a section. So please feel
free to unmute yourself and ask
questions.
Yeah, maybe I can start by
asking you a question. So I am
curious about
the neural network approach for
getting the the regularization
parameter. So I can see that
getting the parameter in the
online face is cheap. But in the
offline phase, you have to solve
for the optimal parameters. So
how expensive is that labeling
process? Actually, you hit the
nail on the head, you know that
that does expand invensis part
at the moment over here.
And
then you're training the neural
network is a piece of cake,
really that that is the easy
part, but finding the optimal
parameters. Yeah, not
necessarily even convex
problems. And we we went already
in some directions that is
reinforcement learning that will
We are learning it on the fly,
what a good parameter is not the
optimal, but ignoring what the
optimal is but trying to
reconstruct the image of the
optimal parameter. So trying to
ignore that one. However, so far
that is also computationally
expensive and reinforcement
learning is not really proud to
converge very fast. So, that is
something we are working on
right now. But
good question. Very good
question. I see. Yeah, thanks
for the answer. So,
so, is there a question from the
audience?
Yep.
Yeah, thanks for great talk. I'm
PhD from UT Austin. So, I just
following
single and quiet questions, I
just follow that and
I think there is a paper that
people reach the, the author,
they, they train the trainer
parameters in the inverse
problem framework, they train
the
regularizer and
regularization parameter at the
same times. And they achieve a
better than the normal thicken
up regulations. I mean, in that
work is like, not only trained,
optimum regularization
parameter, but they weren't so
trained.
I think the inverse map at the
same time, so, yeah, I just
mentioned that. So, you can look
on that and coloration here are
talking about 10 Bhutan's work
on then.
No, no. Okay. Okay. So there is
some work on there as well. And
what we try to avoid over here
is learning the inverse map from
from b to x, then, that is the
inverse problem. And I know that
there's tons of work out there,
and it's very interesting, but
we wanted to keep the physical
model really in place. We didn't
want to touch this piece. But
you're right, there's a lot of
interesting workout.
Nevertheless, whatever paper you
have, there in mind, please send
it to me, I'm very interested
about developments, which are
their true. Yeah, it'd be
because what I have in my eyes,
you know, like,
instead of, we just waste a
resource to train only the
regularization parameter, right?
Learning, like the the approach
learning regularizer they also
have the same meaning. They
include the optimum
regularization parameter with
the priors, like the,
like the proper regularizer for
inverse problems. So which, like
we have, like one,
one cue to birth, something like
that, instead of only white
realization, I wish. So to be
honest, we That's why I did it a
bold face. So we learned not
only one regularization
parameter, we did multiple
different things. One thing is,
for example, what we learned,
which was was interesting, how
many
iterative assaults I should do
in my inversion process, because
that is, for example, implicit
regularization, right? So then I
have my V, and I will get how
many iterations? Should I When
should I start this my
directions? Right? Other things
is, for example, you might want
to have
a mean or some covariance
information, right? So you want
parameterize covariance or so
you want to maybe learn that
one? Yeah, this is these are all
different option, which, which
is really great. And we haven't
explored everything yet. But I'm
really very curious. Please send
me the paper or the link to the
paper. Yeah, thank you. Yep. And
yeah, I just like, one one was
not like you mentioned about big
data. inverse problem, right?
And then if we have big data,
and we need to do further
optimize around for training
data, I think is very expensive.
Yeah. So there's some work we
did on iterative. So it's on
sketching, it touches sketching.
If you have your larger and you
just use pieces of your data.
And there's relationship is
between the sampled
regularization parameters a SAM
add regularization to the sample
problem to the overall
regularization parameter. And if
you're doing interdit sell
something you can actually learn
the regularization, why you are
going, which is very
interesting, and we applied this
For for linear problems, this is
called slim tic sample limited
memory taken off. Or then for
neural networks. This is called
Sample limited memory training.
So slim train. Oh, do you have
that work on your watch scholar?
Yeah, it should be. It's called.
If you look slim train, then you
will find it. I hope so. Okay,
thank you. Great. Yeah, thank
you so much.
Okay, so it gets some fruitful
discussion. So are there any
more questions from the
audience?
So, if we try to
this is, this is in down. I'm
currently a postdoc at Purdue
University. And thanks for your
wonderful talk. My question is
related to Kim, maybe turn to
page 23rd Or somewhere, or you
have figures showing the how the
accuracy will change with
respect to the choice of
regularization.
This one, yes, yeah, this figure
on the left top or at the top?
And I'm wondering that for the
data driven case, we actually
have the noise model, right. So
we have some principles that we
can actually choose a relative,
okay, parameter mu. Right. So
maybe not an optimal for each
measurement, but it's an okay,
one. So my question is that was
a reconstruction be quite
sensitive to the choice of mu
when it is near this relative
good regularization parameter?
That is an extremely good
question, right? And first of
all, I want to answer, it always
depends on the application,
right? So how sensitive your
regularization parameter is,
right? We see here, for example,
their regularization parameter
with 10 to the minus four and 10
to the minus two, will give a
give me the pretty much the same
result, right? And that
if we have a good method to just
a priori, estimated, plugged in,
right, that that will definitely
help. If I'm looking though, at
the discrepancy principle, or
yeah, you UPI E or generalized
cost value, for large scale
problems, they're extremely
expensive, because you need need
to invert this system multiple
times. Right. So and that
becomes very expensive. And
that's why we are currently
working on using the DNS
particular for this problem, but
also including information about
the operator. So that not only
be but also the operator, just
some small information is in
there, that we can have a quick
information about
the regularization parameter,
and you're right, maybe
additional information, maybe
noise variance. If I know that I
should plug it in, right, I can
get out. There's something out
and I would love to include
that. Yeah.
Thank you, thank you for your
answer.
I yeah, I just like have the
following command on this one as
well, there is active subspace
methods for inverse problems.
So,
actually, I did we shot on that
and if we apply an active
subspace
or inverse problem here, so we
all latch, like over
regularization parameter, we we
we still get good results like
the others a real robot, not
squid over realisations
parameter. So you will not have
the inaccurate go blows up on
with the lacks regulation
parameter.
Maybe I don't follow, follow I
you saying you want an iterative
approach to just use
large singular values
essentially, to reconstruct, or
do you want to? Yeah, yeah. can
apply that. Yes. Yeah, that
would be an iterative
method. And but that is
typically more for L to
regularization. For our one, it
becomes a little bit more
difficult, right?
Yes. Yeah, I agree. Yeah. Thank
you.
Okay, so if there are no more
questions, let's thank antiA for
his wonderful talk and sharing
his excellent results of us.
Okay.
Recording here